cette conférence de presse pour freiner
l'hécatombe dans les ch et celle dés le
premier ministre et la ministre de la
santé lancé hier un appel aux médecins
spécialistes et aux travailleurs
humanitaires ce qu'on leur dit
aujourd'hui c'est que la mission
humanitaire là elle est au québec elle
est en ch et celle des besoins de
nettoyer au placement nettoyez pas ça se
joue à mu ou un médecin spécialiste et
travailleurs humanitaires
la pédiatre est revenu à montréal en
mars après des années de missions en
zone hostile
elle avait mené le combat contre l'ebola
quand elle dirige médecins sans
frontières moi je me rappellerai
toujours et je pense que je regardais ce
toujours avec moi et on le voit
présentement que la kfw 19
c'est ses doigts nos patients mourir
c'est de les voir mourir tout seul la
médecin est une des rares spécialistes
des pandémies dans le monde avec autant
d'expérience terre mais ottawa et québec
ont décliné son offre de service vous
mon sens de l'impuissance et surtout du
fait que ça fait 25 ans je suis
humanitaire que j'ai travaillé dans les
plus grosses épidémies et pandémies du
monde et je pense que j'ai un petit
savoir-faire que j'aurais voulu faire
profiter et partager ici dans mon pays
mais j'ai pas réussi à percer l'équipe
de crise et pouvoir offrir à mes
compétences
la pédiatre pratique à sainte justine
mais l'hôpital n'étant pas débordés elle
voudrait aller en ch sld
pour elle les mesures de protection
doivent inclure un test je trouve que
c'est important sinon vital que tous les
gens qui vont aller travailler en ch et
celle des se fasse tester avant je
comprend l'urgence mais il faut pour
ajouter au problème
on sait que des porteurs asymptomatiques
et on sait que quand sur une population
vulnérable
on apporte le kobe 2009 c'est
l'hécatombe
une rare sortie au parc pour la famille
de celui là et il y une pédiatre formés
en algérie comme beaucoup de médecins et
d'infirmiers étrangers qui n'ont pas
encore obtenu le droit de pratiquer au
québec
celui-là est rongée par l'impuissance
j'ai le coeur brisé en voyant ce qui se
passe je me suis proposé pour aider j'ai
pas j'ai pas reçu d'appel comme
plusieurs autres médecins à qui nous
avons parlé
la pédiatre s'étaient inscrits dès le
premier jour sur le site je contribue
mais en vain s'il ya des personnes qu'on
ne pas appeler moi j'ai invitant de
refaire singh sur le site et on va
s'organiser pour les contacter
rapidement suis là pour aider et
surtout en voyant ce qui se passe à nos
aînés je suis prête à faire n'importe
quoi aider c'est ça donc même comme
préposée aux bénéficiaires
oui même comme préposée aux
bénéficiaires jeu paraît quand même aux
proches de personnes aînées je peux
quand même et santé utile médaille
préposés aux bénéficiaires dans un
sachet celle des à québec
à cuba il était médecin de famille elle
espère que la crise actuelle incitera le
gouvernement à devenir plus flexible
avoir une ouverture plus détestés on est
capable de montrer le connaissait les
marques dans l'apport de nos pays oui
c'est sûr qu'avec des choses comme des
prêts un essai sur médecine on appelle
les jours mais nous donner la
possibilité de montrer leurs compétences
pour l'instant mme aïda a surtout hâte
de retourner travailler comme elles
avaient des symptômes
elle a été testée pour l'aco vides il y
a dix jours elle attend toujours les
résultats
ce fils et une expertise qui pourrait
être très utile surtout en temps de
pandémie mais en ontario les diplômés
étrangers les médecins avec des diplômes
étrangers peuvent prêter main forte
oui dès la mi mars à genève le
gouvernement au terrier a assoupli les
règles de pratique pour les médecins
formés à l'étranger donc on a commencé à
accorder des permis de pratique
temporaire de 30 jours renouvelable une
fois
alors tous les médecins formés à
l'étranger ne sont pas admissibles il
faut avoir réussi un certain examen
médical au canada il faut les candidats
doivent eux mêmes trouver un hôpital
prête à les accueillir et un médecin
prêts à les superviser mais ça reste une
porte ouverte
super intéressante mais la mesure a été
si peu publicisé qui a eu que douze
médecins qui ont porté leur candidature
et 10 ont été retenus mais depuis que la
vi ll be ci a publié cette information
il ya une dizaine de jours c'est des
centaines de médecins qui ont depuis
rempli le formulaire pour être
admissibles à ces contrats temporaires
est ce que le québec pourrait faire la
même chose alors ce n'est pas prévu pour
l'instant il est on nous dit au bureau
de la mine
str de la santé daniel mais cannes que
pour l'instant il n'est pas question
d'assouplir les règles pour permettre
d'émettre par exemple d'assouplir les
règles pour des permis restrictif on
nous dit que ce n'est pas complètement
exclu mais on n'est pas rendu là que les
besoins au québec ce sont surtout des
besoins pour des infirmières et des
préposés
mais vous le savez le parcours des
combattants est aussi très importante
pour les infirmières formées à
l'étranger et elle demande à ce que ces
règles là soit assouplie très bien merci
beaucoup sophie je vous en prie